TRYING TO TRICK PA VOTERS INTO
DOING IT.
>> GREG: GREG THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Laura: AND JOHN FETTERMAN HAS
FINALLY AGREED TO DEBATE HIS GOP
CHALLENGING AR MY NEXT GUEST DR.
MEHMET OZ, IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
LATE NEXT MONTH, JUST TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
SO THERE'S A FEW CAVEATS THOUGH
FROM UNCLE FESTERMAN.
HE WANTS TO USE LIVE REAL-TIME
CLOSED CAPTIONING MONITORS AND
ACCORDING TO THE OZ TEAM
FETTERMAN WANTS TO HAVE TWO
PRACTICE SESSIONS IN STUDIO
AHEAD OF TIME.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE OTHER
PARTICIPANT IN THAT DEBATE DR.
MEHMET OZ US SENATE CANDIDATE
REPUBLICAN PENNSYLVANIA.
DR. OZ WE SPOKE WITH THE
FETTERMAN CAMPAIGN AND THEY
DENIED THE PRACTICE SESSIONS
CLAIM SAYING BOTH CAMPAIGNS WILL
BE DOING PRE DEBATE WALK
THROUGHS THAT ARE STANDARD IN
EVERY POLITICAL DEBATE THAT'S
NOT A PRACTICE DEBATE OR
WHATEVER THE OZ TEAM IS SPINNING
THIS AS.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> ALL I KNOW IS JOHN FETTERMAN,
HE'S BEEN DODGING ALL QUESTIONS,
NOT JUST DEBATE QUESTIONS BUT
THOSE FROM THE PRESS AND FROM
VOTERS, WHICH IS, FRANKLY,
INSULTING IN A DEMOCRACY.
I THINK HE'S DOING IT TO AVOID
THIS RADICAL LEFT IDEOLOGY THAT
HE HAS AND HE DOESN'T WANT TO
DEFEND IT.
BUT UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE, HE
HAS AGREED TO THIS SHORT DEBATE
AS YOU POINT OUT.
HE DOES WANT CLOSED CAPTIONING
AND WE WERE TOLD HE WANTED A FEW
REHEARSALS I GET I'M A PHYSICIAN
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO DEAL
WITH A STROKE AND HEART FAILURE.
I'M FINE TAKING REHEARSALS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE EXTRA TIME
IN THE DEBATE SO WE CAN ASK MORE
QUESTIONS, INCLUDING THE
WASHINGTON POST HAVE SAID YOU
HAVE TO HAVE MULTIPLE DEBATES,
PLEASE HAVE THEM EARLY SO THAT
VOTERS GETTING ANT TEE BALLOTS
NEXT WEEK DON'T HAVE TO WAIT A
MONTH AND A HALF.
>> Laura: DR. OZ SORRY TO
INTERRUPT BUT ARE YOU GOING TO
AGREE TO THESE TERMS WITH THE
CLOSED CAPTIONING SITUATION THAT
HE'S ASKED FOR?
I'M NOT REALLY GETTING THAT.
ARE YOU AGREEING TO THAT?
>> I'M GOING AGREE TO ALLOWING
HIM TO HAVE CLOSED CAPTIONING
AND OTHER CONDITIONS THAT HE MAY
DESIRE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR HIM
TO DEBATE.
I DO BELIEVE HE OWES
PENNSYLVANIANS AN HONEST
ASSESSMENT OF HIS HEALTH NOT
DOUBLE SECRET PROBATION TESTS
THAT WE FIND OUT ABOUT ON
TELEVISION BUT REALLY GIVE
VOTERS ACCESS TO WHAT'S GOING ON
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE, ALL VOTERS,
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE PROCESS.
LISTEN, I'M SKEPTICAL OF WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IF HE'LL SHOW UP
IN THIS DEBATE SCHEDULED TWO
WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION, HE'S
OFTEN A NO SHOW DOESN'T SHOW UP
FOR HIS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S
JOB.
YOU BRING UP SOMETHING REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THE LIBERAL PRESS HAS BEEN EYING
THIS ISSUE OF HIS HEALTH AND HIS
RADICAL POSITIONS.
THIS MAN CARES MORE ABOUT
CRIMINALS THAN THE INNOCENT.
NOT ONLY HAS HE HIRED TWO
MURDERERS, CONVICTED MURDERERS
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES THAT HE
HAD RELEASED OUT ON HIS
CAMPAIGN, BUT HE'S BACKED A
MASSIVE MIDDLE CLASS TAX HIKE
BUT DID NOT PAY HIS OWN TAXES 67
TIMES.
SO IF THIS BOTHERS YOU PLEASE GO
DR. OZ.COM AND SUPPORT ME
BECAUSE MONEY IS POURING INTO
HIS CAMPAIGN TO FACILITATE
GETTING THIS ELECTION TO THE
CANDIDATES.
THEY'RE MANUFACTURING THE
CANDIDATE.
HE'S NOT OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL TALKING TO FOLKS ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
FOLKS DON'T KNOW WHAT HE STANDS
FOR YOU REQUEST ONLY FIND OUT BY
WATCHING COMMERCIALS.
I HAVE I'VE BEEN OUT EVERY DAY
DOING INTERVIEWS.
>> Laura: THEY'RE TRYING TO
CENSOR PEOPLE GETTING OUT
POSTING HIS CLIPS GETTING THEM
OUT IN SHORT FORM WAY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA ALLOWING PEOPLE TO SEE
THEM SO THEY'RE NOT ALLOWING
THAT EITHER, GETTING CCP LIKE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE VOTERS
BECAUSE FOX SPOKE TO A FEW
PENNSYLVANIA VOTERS THIS WEEK.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE LEFT US DOWN.
>> LOOK AROUND.
WATCH THE NEWS.
IT'S AWFUL.
I CAN'T DO IT ANYMORE.
>> I HOPE THAT THE REPUBLICANS
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND SENATE
BECAUSE WE NEED TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE STABILIZATION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT
THE POLLS STILL SHOW HIM
LEADING?
GIVEN WHAT'S HAPPENING, THE
GLOBAL RECESSION'S UPON US
ACCORDING TO THE FED-EX CEO
TODAY?
>> HIS LEAD IS SHRINKING BY THE
DAY.
I KNOW THAT I'LL SUPPORT POLICE
AND I'LL ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT'S WHY THE FRATERNAL ORDER
OF POLICE ENDORSED ME
UNANIMOUSLY.
THAT'S WHY WHEN PEOPLE WHO WORRY
ABOUT CRIME VOTE FOR ME.
THEY DON'T WANT DRUGS, I THINK
FENTANYL ENTER OUR STATE WE'RE
NUMBER THREE IN OVERDOSES, HUGE
AREAS OF OUR CITY KENSINGTON IN
PHILADELPHIA UNINHABITABLE WITH
ZOMBIES WALKING AROUND WITH
NEEDLES IN THEIR NECK THEY DON'T
WANT THAT.
FETTERMAN LOSES THOSE VOTES.
HE BELIEVES HE'S ABOVE THE
PEOPLE AND LAW AND IT'S CATCHING
UP TO HIM.
WE WILL WIN IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Laura: DR. OZ I THINK YOU
SHOULD COME INTO THE DEBATE WITH
YOUR OWN HOODIE AND MAYBE A
STETHOSCOPE AND THEN TAKE IT OFF
AND THEN HAVE YOUR REGULAR SUIT
ON.
THIS IS THE WHOLE HOODIE THING
IS JUS